bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de la marque chérie que j'ai toujours
tendance à prononcer xiaomi alors c'est
chahoumi et on va en parler parce qu'ils
ont un tout nouveau produit qui a été
annoncé il ya pas longtemps c'est le
mime x2 est c'est ça on en parle
maintenant
schumi c'est effectivement un gros
constructeur chinois qui va bientôt
arriver en france commencent à arriver
en europe et qui fait parler de plus en
plus de lui parce qu'ils ont des
produits qui sont très abordables pas
forcément cher mais vraiment d'une
excellente qualité est là ils ont
présenté il n'y a pas très longtemps le
jour du lancement par wade ep20 ep20
pros ils ont annoncé le minix deux aces
alors y'a pas longtemps au mwc j'ai pris
en main j'ai testé le nid mx2 la vidéo
est ici
le produit est vraiment très très bien
déjà et là on arrive sur la version s le
minix de hesse qui en tout cas pour
l'instant malheureusement est réservée
au marché chinois
mais rassurez vous il va arriver très
prochainement en france puisque de toute
façon xiaomi devrait arriver en france
cette année donc on va regarder ce cas
ce mix de hesse dans leur antre qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir en faire et en quoi
est-ce qu'il est super cool et super
sexy alors déjà ce truc est super cool
c'est design lâché au mifo vraiment les
choses différemment des autres
là où les autres vous met de plus en
plus des encoches en eau des petits
matches comme sur l'iphone 10 et sur
d'autres produits
là effectivement pas de notch on a un
écran qui vient vraiment flirter avec le
bord du haut et on retrouve les caméras
en bas à droite de l'appareil alors
effectivement la bordure en bas à droite
est beaucoup plus grande
mais ça change et ça propose vraiment
une vraie alternative quelque chose de
vraiment différent efforts pour coup
c'est vraiment intéressant c'est un
écran amoled de 5,99 pouces fhd plus
2160 pixels par 1080
il est un cadre en alu un corps en
céramique un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui se situe au dos de
l'appareil
l'écran c'est un format 18/9 une dalle
ip slcd il ya des tout petits une
bordure sur les côtés c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est en tout cas je
trouve moi super esthétique à l'arrière
vous avez un double module photo avec
une caméra 12 mégapixels sony mx360 3 et
une deuxième caméra 12 mégapixels avec
un zoom optique x 2 côté photo vous
inquiétez pas ça fera franchement la
faire vous avez du slow motion en 720p
sur le modèle précédent en 120 images
par seconde là sur celui ci
vous avez du slow motion en 1080p c'est
à dire en full hd en 120 images par
secondes et vous pouvez aller en 240
images par seconde en 720p c'est pas du
super sous le mot en 960 images par
seconde en full hd comme le sony higgs
est 2 c'est pas non plus du 720p en 960
images par
seconde comme sur les samsung galaxy s 9
et s9 plus mais pour avoir des petits
ralenti pour vous faire plaisir et voir
des choses qui sont vraiment sympas sa
frappe en avant safra fondamentalement
la faire côté processeur on a un
snapdragon 845 une bête de compétences
et en produit qui marche très très très
bien qu'on va pouvoir retrouver soit en
s'y giga de ram soit en 8 gigas de ram
et pour le stockage vous avez 64 128 ou
256 giga mais sans voix détail tout à
l'heure avec les prix ensuite il tourne
sous android 8.0 oreo avec une surcouche
mi-8 neuf maisons chez home il vous avez
de la recharge par induction vous avez
une batterie de 3400 militante erreur de
lieu le betis et du bluetooth 5.0 du nfc
pas deux prises jack là dessus pour le
coup il va falloir vous en passer et
comme je le disais pour l'instant c'est
un produit qui est réservée au marché
chinois néanmoins j'ai les tarifs
converti alors si vous voulez un produit
en 6 giga de ram 64 giga de stockage et
vous coûtera 423 euros hors taxes pour
le produit si giga à 128 go de stockage
462 euros hors taxes et pour le 8 gigas
de ram et 256 go de stockage 513 euros
hors taxes on imagine que forcément des
tarifs en vente en france seront un peu
plus cher bien évidemment alors je suis
obligé pas si vous connaissez c'est
vraiment un consultant chinois qui a une
profondeur de gamme qui est vraiment
dingue
vous avez les smartphones vous avez des
tablettes des caméras à 360 des
ordinateurs des robots des aspirateurs
des smart work as hvr drones fin voilà
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment très très très large qui
propose beaucoup de produits c'est
vraiment une marque à surveiller est une
marque qui va être de plus en plus forte
et dès qu'elle va arriver en france
d'être vraiment une marque très très
très puissante si vous voulez on compare
un petit peu shiomi à samsung l'un
chinois l'autre et coréens mais par
contre ils ont tous les deux une gamme
qui est hyper large alors effectivement
à ma connaissance pour l'instant chez
omis n'est pas positionné sur
l'électroménager peut-être mais en tout
cas je n'ai pas cette information mais
en tout cas elle a vraiment des produits
où elle a une game à 360 degrés donc
pour relier votre téléphonie mobile à la
réalité virtuelle pour avoir un drone a
piloté par tous les pores optimisé
c'est vraiment super bien et tout ça à
des tarifs défiant toute concurrence
alors pour avoir testé
le mx2 j'ai trouvé déjà très très bien
je trouve qu'il est hyper sexy qui
tourne très très bien j'ai testé ya pas
très longtemps le rêve ni 5 + qui
marchait aussi très très bien
fondamentalement en terme de budget
c'est pas très cher et ça fonctionne
super bien là j'imagine que ce nid mx2
est ce une fois de plus va être un
excellent produit on n'est pas sur des
produits d'entrée de gamme dont les
sondés produit milieu de gamme avec de
la puissance avec hun sen dragon 845
quand même un super pro viticole comme
avec de la ram avec de la mémoire avec
du stockage
donc c'est vraiment une marque est très
fort qui va emmener à se développer
énormément et à mon avis
fondamentalement vous serez pas déçus en
tout cas moi je trouve que ces produits
sont très bien je trouve que la marque
est hyper sexy voilà je pense en tout
cas se produit lorsque je pourrais le
tester que je l'aurais en main le minix
de s on en reparlera
parce que fondamentalement c'est une
marque dont on va parler plus en plus en
france
vous dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà testé des
produits de xiaomi est-ce que vous en
avez un
est ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous pensez que vraiment
c'est une marque qui peut aller
concurrencer des marques comme moine
plus comme au nord et même comme samsung
et comme d'apple mark et moi tout ça en
moto parce que je pense que vraiment
xiaomi c'est une marque qui la prend de
plus en plus de place dans nos foyers et
dans nos poches avec nos smartphones les
tablettes les ordis et compagnie merci à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo comme
d'habitude vous invite à mener c'est des
jolies pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on
va parler toujours plus de technologies
que ce soit des smartphones des
tablettes même de la robotique à plein
de choses qui vont arriver des
entreprises aussi françaises innovantes
ya plein de trucs super cool
donc restez connectés merci à vous et à
très bientôt
je vous embrasse d'ici là soyez sages et
portez vous bien
[Musique]